welcome to a special episode of tech
news briefing for Monday April 17th I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
this is the third installment of our
series artificially minded where we look
at how artificial intelligence is
changing our lives livelihoods and
culture the first two shows AI 101 and
your AI questions answered can be found
in this feed they're a great way to
understand the background and some more
interesting things that AI does
today we're going to talk about
something that has been raising a lot of
concern recently
artists fear that generative AI could
replace them it's just doesn't make
sense to pay an artist and to wait three
weeks if you can get it like for
essentially nothing
air generation tools have already been
used to make a prize-winning picture
comic books and magazine covers and that
has a lot of artists worried now there
are a lot of questions about the
information the art used to build these
AI art generators it's even the center
of some lawsuits but today that's not
our focus on this episode we are looking
at the way AI could upend artistic
Industries after all mechanization and
automation replaced workers in technical
Industries think switchboard operators
the human computers that were once
employed by NASA even some modern day
warehouse workers
historically though technological
advancements have contributed to job
creation and economic growth and
creative roles ones that rely on the
human brain to do more than just a
repetitive task have for the most part
adapted to technological breakthroughs
of the past and workers in these fields
have avoided being fully replaced
so is this the moment that shifts
to understand that concern I want to
introduce you to Tomer hanuka an
illustrator living in New York City
Hanukkah earns what he describes as a
middle class income designing the covers
of books and issues of magazines like
the New Yorker and National Geographic
thanks to his distinctive Style
the anatomy of the figures is quite
expressive and Theatrical there is a
limited palette of colors but there are
very bold usually and I strive for um
unusual combinations of color
Arrangements
years developing his style his brand his
artistic identity
calls his cultural capital which is
exactly that recognition that name and
paired with a certain visual approach
and that's something that gives us power
it gives us a place in the conversation
you know Brands need it it gives us some
kind of Mobility
and I think when that thing is harvested
and sold for a subscription
then I feel like it's a very unfair
process
what Hanukkah is referring to are AI
powered tools that generate art you may
have heard of programs like stable
diffusion Dolly 2 and mid-journey if you
haven't used one yourself it's pretty
simple
type in a prompt like illustration of a
woman sitting in a cafe drinking coffee
and the program spits back what looks
like a drawing of a woman sitting at a
cafe drinking a cup of coffee
you can even ask for work that evokes
your favorite artists say then go or
Rembrandt a prompt like a woman is
sitting at a cafe drinking coffee in the
style of Monet can generate unique
results that look like the dead French
impressionist could have painted himself
and Hanukkah says a lot of people have
been typing in his name into these
generators to produce work in his style
somebody sent me a link of what I'm
guessing happened is that somebody went
and used my name in a prompt and maybe
also the word cyberpunk and created 400
images and then went on Open Sea which
is this marketplace where you can sell
collectible jpegs nfts
and sold this 400 image collection under
the title punks by Hanukkah 400 images
using his name
so here is an entire process of creation
and marketing and sale that has nothing
to do with me it's a direct threat on
what I do
and it uses my identity in a way that I
just can't control
bin C says it has it has developed and
put
it toward prevent
it using human moderators it also has
tools to allow sellers of digital art to
add attribution with a badge called
inspired by and another one called
content credentials which says who
created the original graphic but for
Hanukkah it's not just the places where
AI generated art can be sold that has
him worried rather it's the ease with
which strangers can access his Unique
Style for free on ai-powered art tools
after all if they can make art like his
without him almost instantly Why Pay
Hanukkah for his work at all
it's just doesn't make sense to pay an
artist and to wait three weeks if you
can get it like for essentially nothing
of course there's a fine line between
and and actually copying an artist's
work and many supporters of AI art
generation programs say these tools are
just starting points a spokesperson for
stability AI said its tools are
assistive the Way digital cameras or
photo editing software have been for
Photography they added quote we expect
AI to open up new opportunities for the
creative industry and grow the pie for
paid artistic work a spokesperson for
openai the maker of dolly also mentioned
photo editing software as an example of
how technology has impacted artists in
the past they acknowledge that AI would
likely have an impact on jobs and said
quote the nature of many jobs will
change jobs that never existed before
will be created others may be eliminated
mid-journey did not respond to a request
for comment
painters graphic designers concept
artists have all raised concerns that
part or all of their livelihoods could
be snatched away by people using these
programs but they're not the first
creative professions to deal with the
emergence of new tools specifically the
introduction of artificial intelligence
for example the film industry has been
using AI for a while now
and some in the industry say it actually
makes their work easier by taking away
the more mundane or repetitive tasks
right now I don't think anyone would
have noticed that I used AI in any of my
work because I'm kind of using it for
like technical stuff Evan halleck is a
visual effects artist who recently
worked on the oscar-winning film
everything everywhere all at once helic
has worked on commercials music videos
and films for everything everywhere all
at once he says he mostly cleaned up
shots removing things from the
backgrounds of scenes he also made a lot
of versions of Evelyn the main character
when she's flying through the Multiverse
and during the film and in previous
roles he used AI tools to assist in his
work
these aren't generative AI tools but
they help ease some tasks particularly
for a process called rotoscoping if you
didn't shoot on a green screen and you
want to put something behind that object
you have to manually cut them out and in
film it's 24 frames a second so you have
to cut them out 24 times per second it
famously used to take really really long
periods of time and no one that I know
just truly liked doing it it could take
like
three four days for seven to eight
seconds
so if you film an actor in a city but
the scene calls for them to be on a
beach you've got to spend hours cutting
them out of each shot and placing them
over a shot of the coast but Hallock can
cut that time drastically using
ai-powered rotoscoping tools and he says
the time he saves frees him up to work
on more creative tasks
the first time he used it was about two
years ago and he's continued using it
but the thing is halleck a freelancer
hired by films often used to Outsource
this work to others who could make
anywhere from 500 to over a thousand
dollars a day he says now with AI tools
he doesn't need to hire them
and as these tools become more common in
the industry even helic acknowledges
they could have a big impact on who gets
hired and how much money films put
towards tasks like visual effects
I think eventually rates may go down as
things get easier rotoscopers famously
it can take five six days to do things
and if it only takes a day your budget
goes down quite a bit or maybe not even
raids but timelines might go down the
rates might stay the same but the actual
like timelines that you get will go down
and it's really hard to say just because
everything is just changing every three
months I hear of like a new really
exciting thing Hallock Thinks Big visual
effects houses places that hire
thousands of VFX artists to work on
Films will be hit hardest
so what is this pace of development mean
for the future of the creative Workforce
as we said at the beginning technology
has impacted jobs before but often the
elimination of jobs by technology leads
to the creation of roles that couldn't
have been imagined before there were no
web developers before the internet but a
door-to-door encyclopedia salesman is
hard to come by these days
research from Goldman Sachs found that
two-thirds of occupations could be
partially automated by AI the bank notes
though that AI could lead to the
creation of new roles and new ways of
doing things some artists are already
gaining Fame by using technology to
create art Mike winkelmann who works
under the name beeple broke art sale
records with his collection of digital
images that sold for 69.3 million
dollars though they weren't made with AI
artist Trevor paglin's Bloom a series of
AI generated prints resembling
photographs of flowers is on display at
an exhibition at the Modern Art Museum
of Fort Worth
and Jason Allen a games developer took
home first prize in an art competition
at the Colorado State Fair with his work
created via AI art generator mid-journey
but concerns about technology coming for
more jobs have been rising lately
especially as more generative artificial
intelligence tools have been launched
including AI art generators like Dolly
stable diffusion and also chat GPT which
can write research papers and compose
poems
nearly 20 of the U.S Workforce could be
impacted by this Tech including
mathematicians coders and writers
according to a study by researchers at
the University of Pennsylvania and open
AI the maker of chat GPT which stands to
financially benefit if more of this
technology is adopted
all of this is making this moment feel
different than past developments
the easy thing to point to to say now is
different than it has been up till now
is the rate of adoption and use of this
Technologies that's Matt Bean a
professor of technology management at
the University of California Santa
Barbara
Bean says to understand why generative
AI technology could impact earnings and
opportunities for the future Workforce
you have to understand how it's adoption
impacts workers who aren't totally
replaced by technology
and to understand this concept fully I'm
going to let Bean introduce a piece of
academic jargon skill biased technical
change that's skill biased technical
change
the basic idea there is that when you
have a new class of automated technology
there's some period where no one quite
knows how to use it but when it's we
start to sort of figure it out then if
you have skill and privilege in your job
already and by Pro I'm not I don't mean
capital P privilege here I mean you sort
of have resources you have discretion in
your work you have a quote unquote good
job
that change accrues to you in your
career in a way that enhances your lot
gives you better things to do more
interesting work whereas if you're sort
of below the water line skill wise you
are you're in a job that doesn't require
that much of you that much complicated
skill those are the jobs that tend to
become simplified over time because
they're more immutable to Automation and
so those who are below that water line
tend to often land up with less
opportunity lower pay the jobs are lower
quality and you know they can be more
monotonous for example
result according to
some human workers end up doing very
simple repetitive roles they interact
less with skilled or senior staff and
therefore learn less and have fewer
opportunities to grow in their job
or put simply if a technology allows an
expert to do more better by themselves
then they need less help from somebody
who's a novice who's trying to learn
so why does this matter for Creative
fields
Bean says creative fields are the Canary
in the coal mine because if you stop
asking novices to do basic roles filling
in the background of a large image or
design or cutting out an object 24 times
for a single second of a movie they have
less chance to get their foot in the
door develop industry knowledge and hone
their skills under a more seasoned
artist
this is what Evan halick is already
seeing in visual effects and what Tomar
Hanukkah fears will happen to
illustrators
remember historically economists say
technological innovation has created
more jobs and added more wealth to the
economy
the thing is Bean says the speed at
which AI technology is being adopted is
so unprecedented it's hard to know the
impact on society
the pace and the extent of change that
alone
is unprecedented and should lead us to
pay attention in new ways and not to
assume that it's all going to be the
same creative destruction that has come
before
artists and researchers we spoke to
including the three we introduced you to
today none thought the role of artists
would go away entirely
but as more of their tasks are replaced
with AI Hanukkah helic bean and others
told us it's likely only a small number
of the very best will find well-paid
work as artists and what that means for
the world we've yet to figure out
next week on the fourth episode of our
AI series artificially minded who's
responsible for generative AI if it
behaves badly until then you can catch
regular episodes of tech news briefing
in this feed and if you want even more
Tech news check out our website wsj.com
Today's show was produced by Julie Chang
we had editorial support from Eric
Bellman Falana Patterson and Robert wall
our supervising producer is Melanie Roy
and our executive producer is Chris
sinsley this episode was mixed by
Michael LaValle I'm your host Zoe Thomas
thanks for listening
[Music]
foreign